good day everyone welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and
I am very proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2023 2024 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series
where this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA College of
Arts and Sciences the UVA School of data
science and through a grants from the
National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations's of
biomedical data science seminar Series
has focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme for this year is focused on the
building of part Partnerships for
generative AI training in the biomedical
and clinical research areas where every
Friday we enjoy a wide range of leading
thinkers um discussing the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging areas of AI
methodologies participants selected for
our biomedical data science seminar uh
excuse me biomedical data science
Innovation lab program will leverage
these seminar presentations as vital
material in our culminating inperson
manuscript and Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the bajia
beachfront Resort located in San Diego
California in June of 2024 we are very
excited about this program we feel it's
very engaging and interactive and
dynamic bringing together AI platform
developers biomedical researchers and un
University level Educators to better
understand the power promise and
potential pitfalls associated with the
generative AI
explosion today I am delighted to
welcome our our speaker Dr Amy yaboa
quarum from uh Howard University uh Amy
known collectively as uh and
affectionately as Dr a uh is a scholar
filmmaker data scientist and associate
professor of Africana studies in the
department of afroamerican studies at
Howard University particularly proud of
her African Heritage she works as a data
scientist centering around AI bias data
inequity and inequality and
environmental Justice she currently
employs Africana studies an Africana
studies framework to examine the
intersections of race gender and
technology and Dr a is presently the
director of Graduate Studies for the
master's program and appli data science
and analytics uh advancing Howard
University's first major effort in
becoming a hub for data science social
justice research training for the next
generation of data scientists uh she is
also a pi of the core Futures lab a pi
of the Noah Cooperative science Center
in atmospheric sciences and meteorology
and c-i for the race and Tech Lab in
continuing our 2023 2024 biomedical data
science seminar series theme Amy's
lecture today is entitled clearing the
air for a breathable future unraveling
the biomedical implications of data
pollution where she will discuss the
rapid progression of Aid driven by data
which has transformed Global Industries
uh including a significant impact on
Earth science she'll discuss recent
advances which have revolutionized
weather prediction or system
understanding climate Dynamics research
and Energy Efficiency all through uh the
use of high-speed climate models which
depend upon uh a number of different
computational and datadriven
Technologies um her uh breathable
Futures project at the core Futures lab
uh aims to address data deserts in
marginalized communities um and uh to uh
conduct other work that impact black
impact black communities recognizing
potential dangers of neglected societal
cultural and historical considerations
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you're watching via YouTube thank you
so very much for joining us also our
specially selected 2023 2024 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are strongly encouraged to
submit any questions they have via the
chat feature in their YouTube sessions
where I will synthesize these questions
and I'll ask them for on your behalf in
the last 10 minutes or so of lecture and
with that Amy welcome we are so excited
to have you and we're really really
looking forward to your
presentation thank you very much and
good afternoon everyone uh again uh big
thank you to UVA and allowing me to be a
part of this forum it is an honor um as
a humanist by training I am just always
excited to kind of work with those on
the scientist side the stem side in
helping us find Solutions so um once
again thank you for the this space um
I'm excited not just to present but also
to receive questions um in helping us
build um a stronger future um so to
begin again my title of my presentation
today is clearing the air for a
breathable future and ra the biome
medical implications of data pollution
I'm focused really on data pollution and
I'll speak more about that and what that
means as we go through the
presentation slide so just overview of
um the talk I'll give today I'll talk a
bit about about my lab which is the core
features lab which was guides the
research I will help you visualize data
pollution and what that looks like I
will talk about some of our community uh
our core approaches and the communities
we work in and I'll examine two case
studies which is looking at Louisiana
and Manchester um around this issue of
data bias data ethics and data deserts
and then I'll share um our current
findings and our current U prototype
with our breathable future um project
with an air quality mod and then some
implications that um it may give us to
understanding some biomedical Solutions
or Solutions in which we can work
together um as a science community in
addressing some of these um issues that
have been for many years been a a a
prolonged issue that hopefully data
science um modeling can improve some of
the situations um African-American and
Hispanic and Native communities are um
dealing
with so to start to give you some
background on my lab the Cor te lab
right now is myself as the pi and I have
a research team of students who help
work from um high school students all
the way up to graduate students and our
work is funded from um NSF and um
National Science atmospher National
Center for atmospheric research um the
basil fund ezri we focus a a lot on
mapping and US visualizing what
communities we're looking at the north
star of GIS which is a organization that
focuses on um empowering
African-Americans to join the spatial
mapping community and then um Noah
Cooperative um that at how University we
lead um with other institutions and
looking at the atmospheric side of the
conversation in this project so I just
want to honor those who have funded our
project so in the core features lab um
again to give you some background um
core stands for Community centered
openness research and Equity um Guided
by the the the known conversation that
that data is good now the more data the
better but when we talk about data um
and what it can do we must not forget
the fact that there are individuals
spaces communities ideas realities that
do not have data on them we have yet to
kind of um acquire data on certain data
points whether it's um in communities
where there are women in communities
where there are um indigenous in health
instances where things aren't digital um
there are many data gaps and data
deserts that exist in our lab we um look
to expand the data grid on these um
areas that are um uncovered right and
now in my lab I have three graduate
students three undergrad students and
four high school students so at the core
we're trying to bring Equity openness
and kind of centered communities through
research and
data um this one of my favorite quotes
um that kind of GS the work we're doing
um particularly around Earth science so
when it comes to a science it's um not
new that Ai and machine learning and
many data tools are being used in the
earth science realm whether it's
predicting weathers um but even though
and I'll read the quote and
sustainability science is where big data
and machine learning are quickly
becoming standard tools little is known
about how bias and inequality will
propagate through to the output we are
pulling in data from satellites bios
draft um weather stations and a wide
range of autonomous sensors fishing logs
and even social media sites to plug into
algorithms so we have all the technology
in some case we have all this data right
but at the same time we still have
communities that lack clean water clean
air um and livable living conditions so
as a field um as an institution of
research um what does it mean for us to
be able to imagine new realities for
certain communities but for other
communities that's not the case right
there are ways in which science can um
use has been used to create clean water
um out of the atmosphere right but there
are people who still lack clean water in
their pipes right so um this work looks
at some of the bias that exists when
we're talking about Big Data machine
learning AI even generative AI what does
it mean to not have um in our models
communities that need these Solutions
the most when it comes to Earth
Sciences so what data pollution how us
about what is data pollution so um benar
about as as a framework understanding
the harms of the data economy and the
regulatory responses to address these
issues so um is one thing to say that
data is everywhere right but at the same
time it isn't and um for those of you
who work in the machine learning AI
world we know that um the quality of
your data matters right good data in
your model works fine hopefully you get
good outcomes but when we have bad data
going in right and many times we have
bad outcomes coming out right dat
pollution is the um irr it interrelated
adverse impact that the generation
storing handling and processing of
Digital Data has an ournal environment
social environment and the personal
environment it is unsustainable handling
distribution and generation of data
resources so when we look at data in
itself um data Lakes um many case data
warehouses um many ways in which we're
collecting data there are environmental
impacts that come with that right where
is it stored how do we house it the the
energy use right the cloud space right
there is a strain on the environment
that comes with even having so much data
right on one side alongside not having
quality data right so data poll has
dyamic conversation where we have is it
useful to us to be able for us to um
stand our world um if it doesn't give us
a full picture of what that world looks
like and then what does it mean to have
so much data right even from the
environmental science side when that
data itself is pulling down from the
environment right um Urban heat Islands
um destroying physical communities to be
able to build towers or warehouses right
what what what what happens when we have
that type of pollution
disruption
so my my project first started with um
two incidences that I read about um Meg
I'm helping you I'm a humanist at heart
so I like to tell stories um Jack silin
had put on Twitter um in 2021 he had
taken some time to at the time there was
a hurricane in Texas to look at where
Next Rad um satellites were position so
if you're familiar with the Weather
Service environmental um uh research
there are satellites that Noah um and uh
those who are in weather prediction have
as physical structures in place to be
able to collect data on what's Happening
when it pertains to weather so Jack
decided to kind of plot these satellites
on a map but also overlay percent
population um African-American
communities in Texas and what he found
was in many cases the radius of coverage
and data collection for these satellites
um didn't cover areas where we see a
large population of African-Americans
right so we see right there just in the
structural layout of the data collection
process there's a bias there a bias in
race where from the communication
standpoint when it talks about knowing
what's happening in your community um
how severe that is or how much time you
have to make a decision to leave when it
comes to weather um if you happen to be
in a community that is um largely black
community you may find gaps there and
there has been research that talks about
these gaps between these structures in
data reporting when it comes to weather
right and there's some communities that
have been reported to say that in many
cases you rely get their reported other
they're getting their reports from
another community that doesn't reflect
their own right and some of that is a
structural question with um federal
agencies and how these satellites or and
satellites and structures were placed
right so so we see that
there um another um example that came to
me um and why I kind of jumped into the
conversation was there's article that
came out 2019 2019 that talked about
Louisiana um the state had approved
based upon EPA data for a plastic
company to be moved into cancer alley um
in cancer alley if you're not familiar
with cancer alley this is a area of
Louisiana where um the title says
unfortunately residents um have higher
cancer risk um and it's not by
coincidence but it's based upon their
actual surroundings which are um
chemical plant and Facilities that emit
um toxins into the air so the question
was how does the state approve based
upon the epa's data um to move this move
additional company in this area that's
already um facing um Healthcare issues
air quality issues population decline um
in many cases for profit right so this
would be the biggest Factory um and the
state will kind of be able to get that
reward right so these two questions came
up and um I began to think about if um
earth science if Noah if EPA if
researchers are trained to be using the
generative models right AI to be able to
kind of find Solutions what happens if
you're not in the data
right what happens when the data
representing that's supposed to be
representing your location or your
community is in quality all right so on
one level there's no data right causing
a bias another level the data isn't as
accurate to my specific situation so
Louisiana we see the EPA approving that
um and then same year right the the
social outcry is like how could that
happen how could this how could another
company move in when we already know
things are that bad but then the
response is well the EPA says it's not
that bad right so the question is what
is an EPA government agency that's
supposed to be the um outward facing
neutral party that's supposed to protect
people's quality of living how do where
are they getting their data from how is
that um accurate right um so again much
more articles just talking about what
communities are dealing with where
they're saying they know that the air
quality isn't good um they smell it
right they're going to the hospitals
feeling it um but the EPA um methal
agencies aren't saying
that so again to continue to visualize
again I love telling stories and telling
stories with pictures all right so one
of the main communities which I'll kind
of come back to towards the end of the
talk is Mosa Louisiana U MOS Louisiana
talk about cancer alley um is along Lake
Charles and using GIS mapping um we can
see in this picture Within in a Four
mile radius which is somewhat Mossville
we see um chemical pet prochemical
companies um and plastic companies
around the community so this is Mosa
Louisiana and here we see the companies
that are along this area um if you go to
the EPA website the air toxin screen
mapping you can also visually see
they've plotted all the companies right
that emit toxins with these Green Dots
right so it's not it's not as if
the EPA doesn't know right that these
companies exist these companies are um
emitting toxins they do know right so we
have the community which you can look at
physically then EPA knows that there um
are these factories that also
exist to give you a more better
picture right the EP also reports on
toxin emissions about every five between
every five to 10 years the EP does um a
test of toxins in the air um and within
this um EPA track or we say sensus track
these the list of chemicals that the EPA
um has either in the past noted an
emission of this Toxin and in this time
this is 2019 the level of toxicity in
that specific area with these toxins
right so um it isn't often but the EPA
does take um account of what toxins
happen to be in this area and this this
is some of the data that is used to
create language around cancer alley or
the petrom Metro right so there is data
but not as frequent um as traditional
air quad which we see now at every two
to three minutes all
right so then again another EPA website
more data if you go to the EPA website
the EPA will tell you out of the
facilities that exist within this Parish
right what specific company is emitting
that specific um Toxin and how much
right so more data more data we see here
um I want to zero in on this is again
going back to Mossville in the Mosel
area we have these seven companies that
are around them that emit toxins and
sail is one of the closest ones and if
you look at the sacil um company and the
data that they
providing
um
okay so s is the the S is the um the
company right here most some of the
closest to Mossville um if you look at
this image um and I know people can't
respond to me but this is a GIS map of a
street image um picture and we see this
is Lake Charles which is a blue
generally speaking it should be a blue
um River of water um if you look at a
image of a remote satellite actual image
overhead of the area we said we see that
it's not blue it's brown right so um not
only are people talking about what
they're smelling talking about what they
know isn't um they feel isn't clean
talking about their their rates of
cancer right um You can also see
physically in the water quality there
another Pro part of our project too that
the water quality also isn't good all
right but if we look at um sorry so this
is images of their water quality all
right um just so so we can see um but
according to the city of St um Lake
Charles they'll say that we are pleased
to report our drinking water meets all
federal and state regulatory
requirements right so according to their
data collection um reports they're
saying that you can drink the water it
is safe right so we see some of of
Disconnect with the data that's being
collected on the federal side when it
comes to even drinking water the same as
we see that exists within air quality
with certain communities all right um so
the question becomes what's causing this
bias what's causing this Gap um what is
happening where um at one side we see a
um a sense of the EPA and government
agency saying what what we see is good
um from the A and water but people
aren't seeing that right in many cases
what we see is a disproportionate um
level of burden on many black Hispanic
and Native American communities where
there's there are large biases um Within
These data sources of what people are
experiencing all right um so another
visualization of the map if you look at
ezri from 2013 the same Mosel community
on the right hand side we see a um Geo
spatial map overlay um using Google
Earth of the same area 10 years ago um
and this is 10 years later later with
the amount of construction in the area
right um so we see a decrease in
vegetation which we talk about tree
coverage and air quality um we know just
such large amounts of deforestation
changes your air
quality okay this is the map for these
are all the toxins that this one company
emits which is sasil with the EPA
reported um for three years in a row and
in many cases if you look at some of the
um tox since over time these their level
of admission has gone up all right um so
um and looking at um Benzene we see
Benzene goes from six to 11 almost
doubles in three years right and the EPA
does know this the EPA has collected
data on this um and they have it but the
question is how they continue to report
that the air quality is good all right
so if you go to the uh EPA website air
now and they will say that they they're
just the ones that house the data
that comes from Lake Charles reporting
area right um and you can do this
yourself go to air quality now you can
put in your location and it should give
you a sense of air quality reading and
on many cases um I have yet to see a day
in Louisiana the specific location we
just looked at that the air quality
isn't good or just slightly above um
good into the area of yellow right so
the EPA reports good on a daily basis um
based upon their monitors they do have
in the area
they all show Green as good um sometimes
we see in B Rouge maybe in moderate um
but going back to our map we see here
just green everything is okay um and we
know this is um data that many people
use for modeling this is um what many
people use to understand air quality
issue this is what many people use to be
able to um allocate resources for
decision-making and who needs to have um
maybe equipment or air quality
initiatives right so um in many cases
these agencies are saying that
everything is good right the ozone is
good pm2.5 is good um people's air
quality is good so we can continue to
move forward to make these decisions
that we feel are better improving the
lives of these residents um when that's
not the case what these residents are
feeling um so what has been our approach
our question has been how do we deal
with these biases these gaps in data
right these data deserts where people's
live experiences aren't reflect in the
data that people are collecting and in
many cases this pm2 data from the EPA um
or from the Lake Charles um government
agency they reported by every two
minutes right so what's happening there
where people have large amounts of data
about communities and if I've never
maybe traveled to Louisiana never travel
to Mossville I would think that their
air quality is good right um so what
we've done is we we're looking at five
more than five communities we've added
to most recently um and looking at
what's happening there between not just
the air but also the water um so we're
looking at um and also heat issues um
Miami Florida um The Bronx New York with
River um DC and Baltimore with air the
petol Metro um we're looking at
Manchester Houston Texas caner alley
which is Mossville we've also added um a
community in
Maui the Maui fires the East air to and
so particularly close to the um Logan
airport where they have airports flying
back and forth um Vehicles idling for
long hours how do they talk about air
quality issues when um generally
speaking if you look at their air index
as well the EPA says says that air is
good all right so that's the communities
we're working with and our approach in
trying to understand what's happening is
to ask different questions we've spent
time just not um looking at the data
right and asking questions of data but
also getting to know the communities
we're looking at so our approach has
been getting to know who lives there um
who are they um where they come from how
they get to this community and
interesting some of our interviews we've
noticed that um many individuals have
moved into communities where um these
were areas that were originally zoned
just for industrial use but because of
cost of living and not being able to
afford to live in residential areas
people are moving into industrial areas
or at one point um that place was
residential but over time is changed
over to now be industrial right so this
kind of a sense of um urban planning
right is also an issue in conversation
with some of these air quality
communities right we asking our
community members how do they how do
they experience um the issues they're
facing do they understand what's going
on as far as air quality do you
understand what it means to um read a
two a PM 2.5 reading do you understand
what is toxic and what isn't toxic um
where they come from what what are some
of the cultural groundings and
understanding um earth science
atmosphere research right and how do
they make decisions because in many
cases what we're seeing is um people
don't have access to data right not
having access to data quality data
doesn't help someone make the best
decision so when it comes to Health Care
outcomes and understanding impacts of
what it means to maybe play outside or
um be exposed to such diesel to diesel
fuel um understanding how people live
the daily lives will help us help them
make Solutions um because we cannot move
an airport in many cases we cannot
relocate people who are living in areas
that are industrial so but maybe we can
help in helping them figure out what
decisions they can make better if they
were given um Quality data right and
then some of layers of institutional
racem that exist that we could probably
help support through policy um and
change and just having more information
um so at the core we are focus on
communities of Afghan descent Hispanic
descent and also digigen communities and
helping them understand what it means to
um have access to data one but also give
them the power to be able to make
decisions better with the DAT they have
all right the EPA part the government
agency part that is the part that we're
also thinking about as well um but the
community part is what we're centered on
what does it mean for someone to know
their specific air quality and how can
that help them improve their
lives so in our
um we have um a group of students that
different areas study have soci stud
sociology political science AF American
studies Sports Medicine um Environmental
Studies and Atmospheric science again
our students come from high school
undergrad um and Senior researchers from
our partners at the national Center of
atmospheric research um we truly believe
that some of the solutions that we may
find um may not come in my lifetime so
having younger students as young as High
School engage these conversations
creates a pipeline right creates not
only a career pipeline but also a a
longer um lens in Solutions so in our
lab um we're Community centered but very
intergenerational we know that sometimes
some of our young people have even
better ideas than we do um so that's
something that we intentionally have and
then I skip um the first point um in our
lab in the community we're working on
working in and partnering in um the
students come from those communities so
students come from Miami Florida a
student comes from Houston Texas a
student is from the Bronx students from
Baltimore um and that creates a sense of
um unity and also help speeds up the
Community Partnership because they're
from the community and understand the
community they able to um help us
connect with people in helping them
understand some very heavy issues that
we may not have the solution for right
but we're helping them help us uh help
them in a way that have having somewhat
of an Insider um connection helps all
right so that's the approach we're
taking the communities we are
serving um so the two case studies um I
want to show as far as some of the
findings we have um is mville Louisiana
which I talked about a little bit
earlier so Mossville historically and
getting their cultural story um this is
a community that goes far back as
enslavement so um enslaved Africans um
seven families started this community in
mville
um and over time they grew to be a very
self- sustaining Community um and over
time with the movement of these Petro
chemical companies into the area there's
been drastic decline um and the
community um right now is struggling
just to sustain um itself as a unit um
to the to the point that the exist the
biggest company that exists in that area
which is sacil used to be Mossville High
School all right so all the families
that live in that area right now um go
to work and go to school outside of that
original Community boundary right
because there's so many companies that
have taken over their land that they
have
there so in Mossville did I say yes so
in Mossville the question becomes um how
do the EPA say the air quality is good
how do they have monitors that show um
the air quality is good um but people
are not um feeling that life experience
so one thing that um if you're familiar
with epa's air quality index it does not
include toxins so when we talk about
data bias um and data discrepancies when
you're looking at a air quality index
from the EPA um toxins are not included
in that um number um and that's somewhat
what these communities are dealing with
the fact that toxins in the air and its
ability to not be included in data
points um has caused issues and has
caused tension with them being able to
protect themselves when um decisions are
being made based upon EPA air quality
data all right so there's a major Gap
there when we're talking about decision-
making based upon what data points
you're looking at the infrequency of the
data collection when it comes to air
toxins also points a challenge where if
um the epa's N data only being collected
every five to 10 years doesn't show a
large amount of frequency in people
understanding um the cumulative effects
of such exposure right so unless you
have the equipment or the personal
expenses to um collect that data over
time yourself communities just don't
know how bad it is um they're able to
give they're given some um moments of uh
shots of information um but over time
that Comm conversation isn't um
collected right and what they are told
on a daily basis is that the air quality
is good the air quality is good the air
quality is is
good yes so um presently um the EPA does
have a monitor um in Mossville and that
monitor is right next to one of the
major companies um that permits that um
sends out toxins in the air so you would
think that okay the best solution would
be let's monitor these um companies um
these institutions that are emitting
these toxins and they do have a monitor
um that shows the green
um good thems up from the EPA um but
again these monitors do not test for
toxins right so communities are faced
with what do we do where we know that
there's issues in our air um the EPA now
is monitoring but they're not monitoring
what we believe or we know should be
what's monitored how do we close that
Gap in the data right where um in many
cases this community has a monitor from
the EPA but there are many communties
that
don't
so another community that we're looking
at is in Manchester um somewhat the same
issue um using GIS mapping we see
industrial facilities all around we see
a train yard that also emits pollution
we see sewage and waste facilities um
and this community Manchester um is
residential right surrounded by
industrial facilities all around um and
if you go to the EPA website um to say
what how their air quality is being
monitored you'll see not so much a
monitor in the community the one the
community doesn't this has been turned
off right so that's also another issue
as far as gaps in data um some
structural infrastructure um has not
been sustained in many cases so around
this Maness Community we see four
monitors that are not in use and the one
that is in use that gives you a green
air quality good but that um monitor is
outside and across the river from the
man just a
community right and this is another
community that also has the same issues
of cancer Health outcomes that the Mosel
Community has all right so what we have
begun to do at Howard is um help support
communities figure out how to best um
understand their air quality issues now
this is not something that's new the um
citizen science the open science field
of just allowing people to have personal
monitors um is kind of but it's it's
it's is but it's budding um the most
popular is the purple air monitor that
you can kind of put up plug in and be
open sourced and you monitor your air
quality um with this project we are
looking to create something that is
definitely um it's iot 3D printed
lowcost um and solar powered right so
you don't have to plug it in for power
but we want to be able to provide
community unities at least some level of
um
hyperlocal understanding of their air
quality for them to able to make their
own decision also compare their numbers
to what the EPA or other federal
agencies may be providing um but with
that that involves us one first talking
about creating a data plan right so
we're talking about empowering
communities to understand data um but
many communities lack that understanding
so we we want to talk about data that
means to know what your air quality is
how to read your air quality and how to
help support a private um Network in
ways in which you feel that your data is
not at risk all right and that's one two
we're helping the communities build and
print their 3D um air quality monitor um
we'll deploy that monitor and that
monitor will be um iot so they'll be
able to kind of look at the data on
their mobile device or computer um we
we'll try we'll we're looking to help
support the community understanding if
there is is a bias between their reading
and the EPA or that federal government
agency's reading um and then build
community capacity um in the long run
again we the the idea of moving an
airport or moving a family is not
probably the best solution um but we can
probably create ways to empower the
community to kind of protect themselves
around issues um whether it's filtration
whether it's policy whether it's just
knowing when to go out or not to go out
because of um a quality conditions um
those are the five principles we're kind
of putting into this project called the
breathable FES project um
again which are holding the first
prototype that we have started
with the second prototype that we've
created right now is something that's
more um we feel Community centered so
it's a birdhouse um in that birdhouse
you see um the air quality monitor the
battery the solar panels on the roof um
and the Wi-Fi um microchip that sends
the data to the end user um that we're
deploying our first deployment was at
Howard University at Howard University
in DC right now there's so much
construction um on campus that we were
concerned about the Early Learning
Center on campus so we have Early
Learning Center with kids between three
and six and they go outside to play
every day so we deployed this monitor to
be able to understand what their air
qual levels were and their exposures
were um as they're young and developing
children we understand that um when it
comes to diesel fuel idling um pollution
these have stronger impacts on young
children than than they have on adults
um so this has been our first prototype
that um we deployed and students have
been very excited um and the data we're
getting in we're looking to in the phase
two of this to look at that data and see
if we do have differences in um air
quality exposure um during work hours
during morning hours especially during
the times when the kids are outside
plane um can we find ways to help the
school make better decisions on um how
to create um a less amount of exposure
to them if we know that they are large
amounts of air pollutants in the air so
this is version two of the first model
the students are holding the goal is for
every Community to help us help them
print their own monitor so their monitor
should look like their Community they
should feel like they're empowered to
say that we put this up there for us to
understand what our data is um and that
can possibly help not them not only make
better decisions but if you're a
researcher looking to make decisions for
their Community or looking for data to
run models for what what does it mean to
have clean air for this community they
now have a repository of data points
that is hyper local to their community
and what they're breathing um that can
added on to what other agencies may
have so when it comes to biomedical part
um implication again I'm historian um
also now moving to data science um but
in talking to some of um and this is
kind of focus on the health part and
what are the some of the health risks or
some health gaps we see that come from
data pollution not having these data
deserts or having this data that isn't
quality um flawed scientific conclusions
right um in speaking to health
professionals doctors researchers who
work in the area um they've noticed that
when it comes to illnesses when it comes
to treatment when it comes to
diagnosises when um even they aren't
educated on some of the environmental
justice issues or conversation or
language they are reporting things
incorrectly um so for example many cases
where people are having a large amount
of exposure to a toxin right um without
having that knowledge or background as a
professional um you may categorize maybe
their sickness or disease doe to
something else so there is a gap in in
understanding some of the environmental
Sciences of um toxicity exposure
cumulative health risk that our medical
schools have not conjoined on to be able
to capture quality data right um in our
community in Miami they're looking at um
we're looking at Urban heat islands and
um the impacts of elevated temperatures
um so the weather station May report a
temperature at let's say 75 or 80 um but
people are really feeling
8590 so when people are coming into the
emergency room or coming into the ER
passing out um and a doctor isn't um
trained on some of the health language
around the environmental aspects of
overheat exposure right um when you
happen to be a senior citizen on
medication that is sensitive to heat um
not putting that in the full description
of the chart or the treatment um creates
poor data for us to able to address some
some of these health or environmental
concerns all right understanding Health
outcomes and cause of death um again not
having that language creates a challenge
in us also finding solutions to these
data problems and also modeling and
doing research right if we're not able
to robustly understand the connection
between poor air quality lack of quality
data um lack of um precise data that is
localized to communities um we'll be
modeling for um the not the wrong
feature but but not a future that
matches the future that people are
really living so people are facing
higher and elevated levels of exposure
and we're modeling based upon lower
numbers we're under modeling or Under
reporting what people are Liv
experiences are impair decision making
so when it comes to health behavior um
situations and interviewing people um
particularly those who have asthma in
air quality if I'm using many cases we
may use our cellular phone or watch the
weather to understand what Isen
happening um so we look at my phone I
say oh it's raining I'll take an
umbrella right I look at my phone and
say oh it's this temperature I wear a
jacket don't wear a jacket if you happen
to have asthma and using the air quality
index right to be able to maybe go for a
run um and the air quality index is
under reported and you have asthma we
see right there um a behavioral
challenge right that the fact that you
may go for run they may have an asthma
attack all right so not having quality
data that's being pushing through these
models or pushing through these um AI um
decision um tools um we run the risk of
people making thinking they're making
the best health decision but in many
cases they aren't right if you have
young children who are going out to play
outside um and we know that going out to
play is a healthy Behavior but if you're
exposed to toxins when you go outside
how do we um support that that that
isn't a healthy decision if we know that
at this time of day
we have airplanes who are permitting um
this much amount of toxin in the air
right how do we create um better they
also Transportation um air quality um
particularly with forest fires not
knowing um what is happening in these
Realms specific to your location does
cause challenge the last thing is um the
EPA federal agencies are dealing with
the pm2.5 conversation which is a which
is a certain level of air quality
measure
but there's a whole bunch of literature
Beyond um the pm2.5 at the nanoparticle
level right so they are particles that
exist below 2.5 that there isn't robust
amounts of data all right so at the 2.5
level and around there um some
communities are able to have information
but many communties are are dealing with
Nano particles right about diesel fuel
right these are um particles are smaller
than 2.5 that we're not capturing data
on that has cumulative effects on
people's health that um on one level
having just 2.5 at a local level is
helpful um but drilling down even lower
to see particularly when it comes to
Children what they're exposed to um
indoor and outdoor um would help us be
able to close the gap in these
environmental issues that communities
that lack data on or lack data knowledge
um need to be able to live healthier
lives um so from the bial stand I'm just
excited to hear your questions um and
input um because we spent a lot of time
thinking through who are the communities
that aren't um within this data grid
that need to be put on a data grid um
and then what are the gaps that exist
within that data that needs to be
elevated from a quality standpoint for
us to then move into modeling a um a
better future for them a cleaner future
for them right but at this point um we
lack many data gaps that aren't allowing
communities that need the most um level
of um modeling to be able to see that
they can kind of possibly have a feature
have a brighter or cleaner um drinkable
um future compared to other areas that
have robust amounts of data on them
um I think I have one more slide yeah so
the future um is going to continue to
look at more of these communities that
are have data gaps um there are many
communities that um lack localized
information about their weather right
specific to their location they're
getting information from a nearby
airport about temperature when their
temperature is um sometimes 10 to 15
degrees higher in many case also lower
um and then kind of our goal is to um
have monitors sent out to communities
and whatever Community boundary they
decide um they will have access to their
data so if your researcher want to look
at what's happening in Mossville you'd
have to consent with the Mossville
Community to understand um to get
permission to look at their data right
um and the goal is with AI generative AI
is to possibly triangulate a community's
data so if we're able to get a community
that has maybe four or five homes with
the monitor can we using their data
allow them to be alerted to what they
feel their level of good is so they
Define their own level of good they
Define their own level of what they feel
isn't good and above um but also if
there's a route that is predictively
better in Walking for a child or if
there's a monitor at a park that can
tell a that this is good time to play AI
will be able to help kind of um process
all that air quality data to be able to
give meaningful impact and answers to
decisions they'll make whether it's
playing walking running um or even when
to even change your filters because your
filter may have accumulated this much
amount of toxin exposure um so those
those are some of the future goals that
we have with the project as we begin to
build more
monitors um and I think that is the last
slide I have I want to say thank you and
I'm very excited to hear your questions
and comments um and continue to work um
with the Sciences social sciences and
even the history of these communities be
able to find better
Futures thank you Amy thank you so very
much that was I mean this is an
important topic I think for us you know
as we're we've just entered black
history month and I think that it's very
important that we kind of recognize that
you know a lot of the communities of
color whether they're black or Hispanic
or indigenous cultures seem to be those
that have unfortunately are they are the
ones that seem to suffer the most from
air pollution water pollution
contaminated soils and that as you kind
of point out that these things are you
know they're historically rooted and
that it's time that we kind of recognize
these things and that you know I'm just
kind of curious about some of your
thoughts on these things about the level
of you know sort of intentionality to it
or was it just accidental do you think
that there's something systematic or
structural about some of these biases in
the data collection which are you know
when you look at them you think oh my
gosh the you know they're in Louisiana
there's this whole swap of of folks who
are they're not being monitored um by by
the satellites for example and I'm just
kind of curious do you think that
there's you know was that by Design or
was it just kind of it just happened
that way and we're just we're observing
the negative effect of that in the in
the afterthought or I don't know what
are your thoughts on that yeah so um
research shows that some of this was by
Design it's about urban planning right
so historically urban planning has a
grounding that um historically there
were communities that were valued and
communities that weren't valued and when
it came to the communities that they
felt that were valued they needed the
monitoring all right so these are areas
where we feel that there's other high
also High population density right um
they are the ones that we're trying to
Monitor and we're using this um sense of
value judgment to be able to kind of
predict what's happening next but areas
that we don't feel deemed valuable
there's no need to possibly monitor
those areas so we do see a structural
historical overlay of some
infrastructure right that is used to
collect data that now if we as
researchers today want to be Equitable
we have to think about where am I
getting this data does it um provide a a
full range of coverage on the area I'm
thinking of right so again if I go to
the EPA website I can put in Mossville
it'll tell me something but does that
mean that what it's telling me is really
what I am thinking as a researcher right
so um structurally just things have
historically been places for reasons
that we're trying to kind of undo um but
we're just not there yet and it takes
responsible researchers to just ask
questions of the data as much as we're
modeling um a future um if we Contin if
we don't ask questions of data we will
begin to model a future that leaves
people out what do you think of the I
mean the the placement of the sensors is
probably vital in all of this so as you
kind of pointed out there's a community
that was deemed uh you know to be one
where the sensor should go right and
then there's another community on
another you know some distance away
that's where a sensor should go but it's
the community in the middle which
perhaps is predominantly you know people
of color for example that this you're
interpolating between the two sensors
where the air quality is already good
but it could be that that air quality in
the middle is bad I mean are you is
there a a challenge of the interpolation
or the imputation of that data even if
the data is of high quality it's just
being interpolated wrong and being
misapplied is that a sense that we're
we've stumbled into that too yes we have
um you know placement matters and as a
researcher um the intentions of what
you're trying to generalize or solve um
we just need to be mindful of the fact
that yes these um systems AI it would
take what you give it so um if we
talking about a missing value how we
deal with missing values are important
some may just throw it out it's not
there some may make take two averages
and give it uh um the a to just to get
to that um midpoint right and that does
create challenges because culturally
people are living different and diverse
lived experiences um and having um
Census Data down to the track in many
cases may not be enough all right so
really knowing um the area that you're
looking at um and the Dynamics down to
in many case the Block Level is very
much needed um and there's a there's a
challenge between having in many cases
monitoring also sounds like surveillance
right so the more monit we have the
better right like the more data points
we have the better then we also think
about how much do we over Ser do do do
do are we putting Tech at the level of
over saturation right um and also want
to add that part of the cultural
conversation we had with the communities
is that sometimes um we fail to um we
don't take the time to just speak to the
commun themselves and ask them what do
you think are some of the ways we can
find solutions for air quality issues um
instead of just putting monitors
everywhere all right sometimes monitors
just like the MOSI there's a monitor
right next to the um the the the
industrial facility and it says good so
it's not the monitor it's just how are
we giving meaningful understanding to
what what does air quality mean so it's
a formula so we probably be changing how
we Define air quality what are the
parameters of that um model we're using
maybe we should include more toxins in
that formless that can give us a more
accurate sense of what people are are
living um so yeah it's it's it's very
hard but dealing with missing data um is
very important when it comes to
particularly marginalized communities
what's the role of trust in this you
mentioned you know kind of surveillance
you know it's get a little bit dangerous
just we're monitoring things but people
are worried about being surveilled and
it seems that there's you know cameras
everywhere these days what's the role of
trust with kind of engaging the
communities and making sure that they're
okay with this and that they don't see
ill intent when the best intentions are
are are being sought yeah I know it's
it's hard because for communities that
are facing these challenges um and I say
communities because I'm I'm living with
those communities I've come I've I grew
up in the Bronx and if someone told me
to put a monitor in my house the
question I'll be like okay what are you
monitoring for is is there something
else involved in this monitoring even my
quet living right so trust um science
and research for many of our communities
is a nasty word um the trust has been
broken um for many years um from um just
knowing that uh researchers have come in
Taken information gotten Awards
Publications and left people um with no
outcomes or no Solutions or
um no information or no no credit no
acknowledgement as well um so trust is
very much a part of the data science
journey and being able to find Solutions
and I think for our project what we
start with is what are the questions
that you have about air quality like
what do you want to know and one of the
questions that the family gave us was I
want to know whether my child should go
outside to play today all right so we
can we can create data that can help you
make the decision but if we we're not
we're not clear about the questions that
people have have um that are more
important than maybe the question that
we have what we seem to think are more
important um the trust won't be there
right but I think we need to trust that
people um have questions themselves that
we can help support them using data um
and also educate and Empower communities
um in creating larger research
communities outside of our institutions
but trust is is so important um because
it it's been broken um and as we begin
to rebuild those that trust and create
more citizens scientists we have to
rebuild that trust is there any benefit
to communicating the results from for
example I love your birdhouses I think
those are so great that's kudos to you
for developing that in in the form
factor you've chosen those are great is
it helpful at all to say take the data
from those and communicate those to the
community Through like local news uh
outlets for example you know your your
local weather report for example could
take that information and supplementing
it with regard to you know the the
National Weather Service or whatnot um
you know communicate that to the you
know to the local community so they
become familiar with it yes so I think
the goal with using Ai and of AI is um
when we have large repositories of
localized data they can pull from their
own repositories right and the data can
also kind of be added onto for
historical data so is today a good day
to go out is is is it is it a good time
to go out um compared to last week what
should I kind of do and it does become
very hyperlocal and it can be added to
what they're what they may be um seeing
on TV and Comm and in the newspapers
right but it gives empowers the
community to kind of have their own
control right have their own sense of if
we want to create a community of diverse
meteorologists young people can kind of
have this tool to say I understand what
this says I understand the temperature I
understand the pm2 reading I understand
this and they could be excited about
kind of again building career Pathways
um um if they can have it and it be
translated in their own language right
so for many Hispanic communities it's a
language translation challenge um for
many um other communities who may not be
educated it's a literacy challenge um
but yes it can be coupled with what's
already existing out there but I think
for us we're trying to say we help
helping communities control control
themselves like you can be your own
weather person and you can take your
iPhone reading and this monitor reading
and compare it and see is there
difference what's causing that
difference then you decide for yourself
what you decide what whether you want to
go out or how long or what type of
outfit you want to wear to go out I
should say thinking a little differently
than being like hyper local necessarily
I'm also aware that there are
communities who are sometimes referred
to as the Downwinders right where
there's a a somebody who's or someone
some company that is polluting and they
pollute into their atmosphere but the
wind takes it and blows the particulate
or whatever it is Miles and Miles Away
um and to be honestly the I grou up in a
community that was sort of affected by
that and I'm curious if some of these
sensors you know deployed up in
strategically could help with those kind
of communities as well yes so this kind
of goes kind of the question of like
wildfires right so we uh I guess many of
us in the Northeast were kind of alerted
to this sense of wildfire like spread
like it's coming our way could it be um
used in that way I think yes but that's
a like a larger commercial level sense
of um sharing data across outside that
specific Community to warn someone else
so um there is a whole conversation
around the communication of air quality
and how do we create a network that lets
other people know all be aware of maybe
hyper local conversations that are maybe
coming down your way um and I think
that's that's what AI can do definitely
if we're able to triangulate all these
hyperlocal citizen science monitors into
maybe a massive um interconnected
Network that lets everyone know what's
happening where we can definitely deal
with wildfires or definitely deal with
um communities where um institutions are
the the emissions are just not local but
it's widespread and people know and
people know how to make decisions better
but I think that's where the power of
having more data um and building out um
systems that are networks that speak to
each other from the Environmental
Sciences to the Health Sciences to the
public health to the Health Care System
um people can prepare um and from an
economic standpoint we don't face the
burden of dealing with um so many health
concerns that um could be a behavioral
change if people knew
more Professor Amy cork from Howard
University thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts with us uh as we enter
Black History Month these are important
conversations to
have continue having and to return to um
as we're thinking about how best to use
data and make it Equitable for everyone
and to really help everyone understand
how to you know take advantage of these
data to make life decisions um about
themselves their personal health and
well-being of their communities so thank
you Amy I really really appreciate you
sharing your your research with us this
very exciting thank you thank you you
have a wonderful weekend and everyone
who's joined us have a wonderful weekend
as well